Mr. MISIA, isn't MISIA a
fist?
I'll come help you right away,
so please wait.
You said,
Union
people hurt and
kill infected people, isn't that right?
Even when I was robbed, yes
This child was crying
and calling her name
[Music]
You covered your ears
But I understood I was
robbed of this child again I
finally understood My
heart hurts and hurts so much
Union  People just want you to know this pain, the pain that the
infected have suffered The
punishment that people deserve And
I'll stand by them as an infected It's
finally
time to stop wearing it I
've replaced my position
We should
be able to share our feelings as infected people
Please believe me, I
have no choice but to do this I'm not as
strong as you
Goodbye,
Mr. Hero, Mr.
MISIA, Mr.
Umi,
Doctor
Misha